love this guy not just because he's on
hold hearing me say it but i'll just say
this
um he has called in the show during the
playoffs before
and i'm one of those hosts of a show
where of course
having big name guests on is important
but i'm not one of those folks who's
just like okay you agreed to come on
you lost last night i'm going to make
you call in
i we we gave this man the out we called
him up and said very rarely do we send
our bookers to uh
to say hey you know if he wants to tap
out he can't but nope he is calling in
and he's also calling in a couple hours
after we found out that
the starter for his team is scratched
tonight uh the one and only
justin turner of the los angeles dodgers
how are you justin
i'm doing good rich how are you i
appreciate you calling in did you get
the message that hey if you wanted to
tap out today you could did you get that
message or you're just learning that i
gave you the out to not call in today i
i didn't know
i didn't know i had it now but i
wouldn't have taken it anyway i would
have called in
i appreciate that you're a professional
you're a lead pipe
uh swinging professional uh okay let's
get to the the news
right now uh about clayton kershaw is
there anything that you could tell me
uh about him or what you know of the
fact that he's
scratched with back spasms tonight
justin
uh yeah i think his his back tightened
up a little bit on him and
uh they're just going to give him an
extra day or two to make sure he's
he's full go and ready to go for a start
so i'm not too worried about it i think
he's gonna be all right
um and he'll just take that extra extra
day maybe two
and be good to go okay and then how what
what is your role
uh if any uh with tony
gonzalon tonight getting the start uh on
absolute short notice
what how do you handle your business to
help him handle his
justin well i don't think it was
as short of notice as everyone might
have
believed i think he was on on standby
and knew there was some stuff going on
so uh
you know tony gray he's a he's a former
position player so
uh he's kind of used to the short notice
and playing every day and
he's one of those guys that's just an
interesting guy
i don't think anything really rattles
him he's a huge
i don't know what this has to do with
anything but a huge cat fan so
he's just one of those weird guys i
don't think this is gonna
i don't think this is gonna i don't
think this is gonna rattle this cage at
all all right now i've got
justin i'm sorry i've gotta i've gotta
pull at this strand right here
um so the fact that he's a cat guy
makes him perfect for tonight's start
i think so i think so you know he's got
nine lives he's uh okay
okay i mean he's so into the cat thing
he he he believes in catter day he wears
cat shirts on saturdays coming
off the cat convention what um my
handshake with him
is a little cat handshake like licking
your paws licking your
he's an unbelievable competitor he's got
four quality pitches
um and we have all the confidence in the
world he's he's eager to get out there
and
and get on the mound and give us a
chance to win okay so justin if you
don't mind
i'm sorry i'm gonna keep doing this he's
ready to pounce and land on all four
feet
is what you're saying there you go
that's exactly what i'm saying thank you
wow i didn't know that i did not thank
you sir
you know what you're not the only lead
pipe wielding professional on this phone
call right now
so that's right this isn't scripted
everyone this is this is not scripted
i'll tell you this i've i wasn't
expecting he's a cat guy so he's ready
he's suited for this role tonight i
wasn't i wasn't truly expecting that
uh he's perfect for for all this okay
so um you've been through these playoff
rodeos before
um you know fans uh think anytime
somebody reaches base that the
the series is over for your team uh
being down 1-0 with your guy out tonight
in kershaw uh obviously you have all the
confidence in the world
uh of your of your picture tonight but
how how do you handle your business
with the dodgers being so poised in this
moment
justin yeah we just go about it like
every other day you know obviously
uh winning game one um
you know is is always important and and
obviously that didn't happen for us but
uh by no means did we think that we were
just gonna
you know tap dance our way through this
postseason and
and you know run the table so we we
thought that
uh or we know that this braves team is a
good baseball team we know it's going to
be a dog fight every night and
we're going to gear it up for tonight
and
try to figure out a way to win a ball
game tonight so um
in terms of the circumstances last we
chatted you were in seattle going to
a game in seattle just learning about
protocols and just getting used to
everything what about bubbling up
do you do you like it better than the
way you were going about your business
before
how do you feel about it justin
uh you know what it hasn't been too bad
actually i think major league baseball
did a nice job
uh putting this thing together um
you know we have the whole hotel to
ourselves it's just us and obviously the
braves
um and there's enough activities and
rooms kind of set aside for
for guys to be able to not be locked in
their room all day so
that's nice and things are going good i
think the biggest difference is we're
getting tested every single
day now um so you wake up in the morning
the first thing you do is you go out you
go down and
you do your covet test and you get the
results within 24 hours and
so far everything's been been going
really well and the the test is the one
up the nose is that that one
no we're actually doing the the spit
test so we had a little little
vial and spit and fill it up to the line
and and
and uh there's a cap that you twist on
there with the little blue liquid
oh yeah that releases into it you you
turn it in and you're good to go so
it's not very it's not invasive which
helps that's nice right um
you know doing the the nasal swab which
i haven't done yet i don't know if you
have but i've heard it's
it's a little invasive and if we had to
do that every day uh
that might be a little bit tougher well
um i've done both
i've done the spit one just this very
morning justin as a matter of fact
uh woke up and did that myself and then
i've done the one up the nose
and uh it leaves you your eyes tearing
for a good hour
so yeah if i'm a baseball player um
clearly the spitting one is one i'm more
accustomed to so uh that's the one i
would do if i was a ball player
you know so that's probably that one i
didn't think i'd get into copper testing
with you either but it is an interesting
time
is your is your wife with you do you
have members of your family with you in
texas to watch
or no yeah my my wife's with me um
in fact i think the majority of our
majority of our team has their wife kids
with them
okay here so that's all that's also nice
as well um
and then you know having them being able
to come to the games
is a plus they haven't been to a game
all year so
these these games here in texas were the
first games they were able to actually
attend in person
uh that's been nice obviously it's
always good to play play in front of
them
and then obviously this round um you
know they're letting fan
fans in for the first time so that was
it was fun to get out in front of the
fans last night for the first time
so nobody's heckled i mean imagine the
hecklers you'd be able to hear like
serious rabbit ears on that front
with fans fewer fans in the stands right
justin anything like that
uh yeah i i think it's only 12 000 fans
so it's not like
completely packed out so yeah you can
hear uh
pretty much everything everyone's saying
uh there were some fans last night up in
the top decks who were just screaming
and you can hear that and obviously
playing the braves and their fans doing
the chop and and whatnot you get a
you hear that pretty loud and clear as
well okay i bet i i absolutely bet
all right so um the talk of the dodgers
being the best team in baseball is that
good
is that helpful how would you determine
entering this
i mean it is what it is it's
conversation i think for
for the media and the fans but the
bottom line is you got to show up and
you got to play and you got to
uh find ways to get on base and score
runs and
and you know that's that's the beauty of
the game it doesn't matter what
what it says on paper who's supposed to
win in baseball you've still got to show
up and play
so that's why i love it well let me ask
you this in a couple minutes i have left
with you justin is uh
earlier in the week um i when talking
about you
i said you were very similar to julian
edelman the julian edelman of baseball
because you were somebody that was not
heralded coming in
and has made them at the absolute most
of the opportunity
and then when the chips are down in the
postseason just raising the level of
play how would you rate my analogy
justin i'll i'll take it uh
you know he's got he's got a few
championships under his belt uh which i
do not so i guess we don't compare in
that
but hopefully uh we're looking to change
that
yeah i bet i bet and so and one last one
for you justin
being a follicly challenged man i'm
always asking you about your hair
uh was it cool to have dustin mae as a
teammate did you say that there's enough
red hair and flowing red hair uh for for
dodger blue or
he was kind of infringing on your turf
coming on to the team
no no it's always good to have more
redheads uh
in in professional sports there's not
enough of us so
the whole rumor going around is that
you know redheads are a dying breed so
uh
the more the merrier in my opinion and
it helps that he has a uh
absolute bazooka for her right arm so
it's just always fun
it's always fun to watch him out on the
mound and see him throwing a hundred
mile an hour sinkers and his
long curly red hair flying all over the
place
everywhere yeah honestly i kind of
thought the first time you know
as you know dodger dodgers have had uh
hollywood
all-star teams uh i honestly thought
carrot top was your teammate first time
i saw him
on the mountain justin well he's not
quite he's not quite as funny and and
doesn't quite have the personality as
carrot top but he's starting to open up
and come into his own
uh you know he's he's real quiet and
kind of to himself but
um you know the more the more he's been
going out and the more success he's
having the more time we've got to spend
with him
uh you know he's starting to open up and
and like i said
it's it's awesome having him available
whether he's starting games you're
coming out of the bullpen it's just a
huge weapon
well uh justin i greatly appreciate you
joining the program
um and uh let's get you back on uh
in the next couple weeks too um
certainly uh
uh to learn more about the the feline
habits of uh your teammates
at the very least all right rich i
appreciate you having me on
always always a good time thanks you
right back at you that's justin turner
of the los angeles dodgers hey you
watched all the way to the end thanks
for that
watch more right here